we've been hearing for months now about
how hard it's been for the Trump
administration to book big-name
performers for the inauguration you know
Obama got a lot of big names and they
were seen as being kind of tough for
Trump had people they dropped out well
some are saying with the exception of
acts like Toby Keith and three doors
down they're saying the lineup for
Trump's big day is well some of them are
saying it's kind of bottom of the barrel
ladies and gentlemen I could not
disagree more I think that is wrong
Trump has booked some incredible acts
believe it or not some of them are here
tonight Wow to give us a preview of what
they're gonna do tomorrow
at the inauguration would you like to
see that
please yeah exactly they gotta get out
of here first up first up ladies and
gentlemen its professional saxophone
pointer russell van bones
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Russell ven bones this our next
performer
our next performer at the Trump
inauguration is an American icon get
ready for the comedy stylings of the
Marlboro Man
[Music]
how's everybody doing cool a lot of
people ask me what my biggest regret is
well after four smoking related
surgeries I'd have to say my wife what's
the deal with airline food seriously
what does it taste like I have no taste
buds left
[Applause]
[Music]
up next adding an element of excitement
in danger of the inauguration its
plus-sized American daredevil chubs
danger
[Applause]
Oh No
No well he's dead everybody chubbs
danger Thank You Chuck you know Donald
Trump doesn't need a list stars when
he's booked our next performer please
welcome the bubble popping magic of
Betty Lou Harris
[Music]
[Applause]
look at it go wow what's your problem
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
daddy baby please that's enough Betty
Lou Harris everybody I hear she's got
OCD terrible it's a living nightmare
this next an agro performer is a gifted
opera singer whose only shortcoming is
an irrational fear that someone is
sneaking up behind him
please welcome oh whatever Arturo
Palazzo my bad sorry there front from
the top let me drag it I thought there
was somebody there
sorry Conan gonna try it one more time
hello you cannot you're an idiot Arturo
[Applause]
[Music]
because I got you I got you I got you
now all right course the headliner of
the inauguration he stirred his career
on our show but his conservative columns
in the Wall Street Journal have given
him quite a following among the
alt-right he's always a crowd-pleaser
it's the really tall dachshund
[Applause]
you